Car tester Reinhold Deisenhofer says even
James Bond doesn't get a new company car every
day -- and the Aston Martin DB11's predecessor,
the DB9, showed it.
Its platform was developed for the Vanquish
back in 2001, and its motorization was even
older -- from the era when Aston Martin belonged
to Ford.
In the meantime, Daimler has bought into the
British carmaker, and that's fine if you consider
the current AMG GT models.
Let's see what the DB11 can do, he says.
The official successor to the DB9 is impressive
at first sight -- and not just when it's sunny.
The DB11 is classically elegant, with proverbial
Britsh understatement.
Its design language will be the basis for
all future Aston Martin models.
No sills or spoilers.
Out of consideration for the neighbors, the
car is even programmed for a silent start:
for the first few meters, the noise flaps
in the exhaust remain closed.
But later -- watch out!
Then the engine roars from all 12 cylinders.
This gentleman-racecar churns out 447 kilowatts
and takes just 3-point-9 seconds to rocket
to 100 kilometers an hour.
Its 700 Newton-meters of torque and top speed
of 322 kilometers an hour promise fantastic
-- if eccentric -- driving fun.
Reinhold says the Aston Martin Gran Turismo's
interior is classical.
The perfect bucket seats and leather ceiling
make you go "Ahhh!" when you sit down.
And the instruments are very reduced.
The central console has five buttons made
of real glass.
The middle one -- the ignition -- is surrounded
by those controlling
the 8-speed automatic transmission.
Reinhold is especially taken with the precise
steering.
The only thing he can find to criticize is
that there are too few surfaces to store things..
The cooperation between Mercedes and Aston
Martin has paid off.
The interior feels more modern than in the
DB11's predecessors.
New are the 12-inch infotainment and digital
instruments.
But the model hasn't lost any of its British
charm.
There's top-quality leather wherever you look.
The British end of the partnership gets all
the credit for the DB11's handling.
The car is much faster and more agile than
you'd imagine at first sight.
Overall, it seems very different from its
competitors.
There's none of that Ferrari melodrama or
gut-wrenching Lamborghini roar.
In the DB11, even very high speeds seem routine.
Reinhold says the DB11 definitely has the
"James Bond" feel of an Aston Martin.
It's a lovely GT with the performance of a
super sportscar and the elegance of a timeless icon.
But even when driving at moderate speeds,
fuel consumption never dropped below 14 liters
per 100 kilometers.
He tells us the "DB" stands for David Brown,
who bought the Aston Martin company in 1947.
In 1963, the DB5 became the first James Bond
car -- and served in the films Goldfinger
and Thunderball.